bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode dont la grande qualité j'espère
vous fera oublier le temps que j'ai mis
à sortir
malheureusement j'ai perdu quelques
données relatives aux chroniques de
preuve lorsque quelqu'un a
malencontreusement embarqué mon
ordinateur avec lui alors que je prenais
le train il s'est bien fait avoir je
vais encore miss top
j'ai donc décidé de faire simple pour
cette fois et j'ai repris un sujet
développé dans ce mémoire que j'ai écrit
ça et de moi je connais bien mon sujet
ouais enfin ça fait des jours que tu me
parles des astrologues en termes de
croyance
excuse moi mais l'astrologie est une
science du sert et non place trône au
mit et une science l'astrologie repose
sur des croyances c'est vrai carton
époque on faisait pas la différence
vous savez probablement ce que sont les
astrologues mais qu'est ce que les
astrologues de cours eh bien les grands
princes et du de france et d'autres
royaumes disposer de tout un tas de
personnages dans leurs cours afin de les
servir des médecins des barbiers des
écuyers des cuisiniers on parle aussi de
l'hôtel princier pour désigner tout
l'ensemble de ce personnel je pourrais
faire une vidéo là dessus d'ailleurs
l'idée numéro 3 176 parmi eux pouvaient
se trouver des astrologues dont le rôle
était de produire tout un tas de
documents et de prédiction dans le but
d'aider le prince certains se trouvaient
présents toute l'année à la cour
d'autres pouvaient être appelée
occasionnellement et d'autres enfin
n'avait rien à voir avec la choucroute
mais décidé de réaliser une production
pourra prince afin de se mettre en avant
mais si regardez j'ai écrit une super
prédictions sur vous il va vous arriver
que des bonnes choses
sinon vous embaucher l'exemple le plus
connu d'astrologues et michel de notre
dame que vous connaissez sous le nom de
nostradamus et qui était pensionnés à la
cour de catherine de médicis au 16e
siècle à son service il a réalisé de
nombreuses prophéties que certains
s'amusent encore à interpréter de nos
jours les astrologues dont je vais vous
parler d' a plutôt du 15e siècle mais
comme nostradamus ils étaient pour la
plupart des personnes instruites
bacheliers voit remettre en médecine ou
dans d'autres disciplines scientifiques
parce que pour eux du moins en théorie
l'astrologie était une science très
précise il fallait observer la position
des étoiles des constellations connaître
des tas de méthodes de calcul compliqué
pour réaliser leurs prédictions
as tu vois quand je te disais que
c'était scientifique oui enfin dans les
faits on avait aussi beaucoup de
profiteurs il était facile de dire
quelle roue allait mourir dans l'année
si on savait qu'il était malade qui
allait l'emporter dans une bataille si
on connaissait les rapports de force du
coup il est fort probable que beaucoup
des astrologues sur une base
scientifique réalisent leurs prédictions
en restant assez vague pour plaire à la
personne concernée un peu comme les
horoscopes d'aujourd'hui en fait à
d'autres moments les astrologues font
carrément oeuvre de propagande au
service de leur prince par exemple jean
de maizel aux services de charles le
téméraire réalise une prédiction d'après
les observations d'une comète pour tous
les astrologues les comètes sont un
mauvais présage et les autres
astrologues qui l'ont observé l'ont
placé dans le signe de la balance qui
est celui de charles et téméraire et en
ont conclu que ça sentait le roussi pour
lui genre de visa ne cite que pas du
tout cette comète est placé dans le site
de la vierge et c'est donc louer 11
l'ennemi de charles le téméraire qui
auront à chaud aux fesses
non mais et il y aura des maladies des
mortalités des familles la mort
d'enfants en bas âge et l'avortement des
femmes grosses il y aura des tonnerres
c'est clair des incendies de moisson et
beaucoup de rois et de coran tomberont
durant qu'ils occupent astrologue
croyait dur comme fer en ce qu'il
faisait ce n'était donc probablement pas
le cas de tous
turbine toutes mes croyances tu le sais
ça maintenant nous allons nous
intéresser aux types de documents que
produisaient les astrologues jeu déjà
parlé des prédictions comme celle que
faisait nostradamus qui était ce qui se
rapproche le plus d'oeuvres de
propagande par exemple une prédiction
que j'aime beaucoup déclarent que la
lignée des ducs de bourgogne sera
merveilleuse étonnante est patente et
l'astrologue qu'il a réalisé le c'est
bien parce qu'il a personnellement connu
jean sans peur ce grand homme il prédit
que ces quatre héritiers mâles feront de
grands shows aux gagneront des batailles
etc
sauf qu'on analysant le texte on se rend
compte que la prédiction est bien trop
précisé que l'auteur n'a pas pu l'écrire
à la date qu'il prétend en réalité elle
a été écrite au début du 16ème siècle à
l'époque du fameux 4e héritier mâle qui
n'est autre que charles quint il s'agit
donc d'une fausse prophétie visant le
mettre en valeur
tu arrives à déchiffrer satwa la
paléographie ça sert pas à grand chose
dans la vie de tous les jours mais c'est
vachement cool
les astrologues réalisait aussi des
prédictions annuel qui expliquer le
déroulement de l'année à venir le temps
qu'il fera à la qualité des récoltes il
y aura des maladies ni des guerres etc
mais sera pour la première partie beau
raisonnablement et se rend en de 15
jours chauds et vendu midi ou d'occident
est possible que après aucun show soit
parfois tonnerre tempêtes et vents et
nous fêteront la saint fernand un autre
type de prédiction que j'aime beaucoup
et l'almanach annuel dans un almanach
annuel l'astrologue dresse un calendrier
accompagné des jours les plus propices
d'après la position des astres pour
accomplir telle ou telle action
ce sont donc des oeuvres beaucoup plus
scientifique que les prédictions et qui
se rapproche du fait que les astrologues
sont également médecin parce qu'on ne
les retrouve les jours favorable aux
saignées par exemple par exemple dans
cet almanach qui est le plus détaillé
que je possède
l'astrologue montre quel jour sont
propices pour envoyer des messages
attaqué une ville commencer une guerre
où faire la paix acheter des arbres se
laver se couper les cheveux ou les
ongles donc si en octobre 1426 on veut
se venger de ses ennemis
c'est le jour 1 celui qu'on retient
ainsi le seigneur sait comment organiser
toute son année bien sûr il s'agit de
recommandations sur les jours les plus
favorables
le prince qui les reçoit n'est pas
obligé vais respecter à la lettre ça
serait vite le bordel alors le 28
janvier j'achète des chevaux j'en ai
déjà plein les écuries messieurs celle
qui me dit le 3 mars déclare une guerre
merde je n'ai pas d'ennemi mois bon je
vais bien trouver à mes deux jours après
il faut que déclare la paix ça va être
compliqué et quand est-ce que je peux me
couper les ongles
le 2 mai et c'est dans cinq mois
d'autres à manhac sont beaucoup moins
détaillée et se contente de montrer les
jours favorable aux saignées ce sont les
petits elfes que vous voyez avec
plusieurs rêves quand ces jours on peut
se signer à la folie et dans la colonne
à côté les petits elles correspondent au
jour favorable pour prendre des laxatifs
dans la vie d'un duc
on n'a pas le temps de se laisser aller
il ya deux types de journée celle où on
se fait saigner et celle où on prend des
laxatifs
il existe enfin un autre type de
production des astrologues le carré
astrologique qui comporte des signes du
zodiaque et des chiffres qui est censé
éclairer le futur d'une personne ici
charles le téméraire et marie de
bourgogne à partir de la position des
astres à une date précise
souvent sa date de naissance ou son
anniversaire mais pour cela encore
faut-il connaître la date de naissance
exacte à la seconde près de la personne
dont on veut réaliser caresses trop
logique
la plupart des princes faisait donc
attention à noter la date de naissance
exacte de leurs héritiers mais pour ceux
qui ne s'intéressaient pas trop à
l'astrologie ça leur passé un peu
au-dessus mais du coup il ne pouvait pas
connaître leur destin et oui c'est le
problème que connaît le roi charles vii
qui ironie du sort adore l'astrologie
les son père n'a pas pensé à noter sa
date de naissance exacte certains
astrologues considérons qu'il est d'un
certain ascendant d'autres ne seront pas
d'accord si les astrologues s'en
tiennent à la science ils ne peuvent
donc pas réaliser d'almanach de
prédiction de roscoff pour ce roi mais
le font quand même mais tant pis il
triche un peu pense que ça rapporte
les astrologues avait donc pas mal de
travail et savez même de conseiller au
prince il leur disait si la décision
qu'il s'apprêtait à prendre été bonne ou
non ou même quel type ou couleur de
vêtements une corde et portait selon les
jours toujours d'après l'observation des
étoiles peut on a dit pas de rose le
jeudi c'est un prince ils croyaient
vraiment d'autres étaient plus
sceptiques mes préférés écouter ce
qu'ils avaient à dire et d'autres enfin
n'y croyais pas trop
il y avait assez peu de critiques à
l'encontre des astrologues l'église les
accepter ce qui était le plus condamnés
étaient les deux mineurs en gros ce qui
faisait leur prédiction à partir
d'autres choses que l'observation des
étoiles la géomancie par exemple la
nécromancie du tout ce qui sera pour
chez un petit peu trop de la séance est
vrai voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu
j'avais dans l'idée d'en faire une sur
ce thème depuis le début si ce thème
vous a intéressé outremont mémoire il
existe un très beau livre sur le sujet
de maxime creos arrêt des astrologues à
la fin du moyen-âge
vous pouvez me retrouver sur facebook le
lien est dans la description vous
abonner et me suggérer d'autres thèmes
pour les prochains épisodes
merci d'avoir regardé